hola
pues le tengo una mala noticia
no haber cerveza gratis después del
evento
o sea duro pero hay que asumirlo
mis familias de origen ahora entonces es
difícil que vemos descuentos me cuesta
pronunciarlo
bueno ya rompimos el hielo
imaginémonos que
vamos recorriendo una cordillera
vamos caminando solo recorriendo un
camino
difícil debajo del sol
y ves esas montañas y hay un cruce de
montaña
y se está haciendo tarde está empezando
a hacer noche
y vas con hambre vas con sets
va lleno de miedo e incertidumbre
porque sabes que viene la noche y no
sabes qué va a pasar
en el monos que vuelta del camino vemos
esa cabaña de montaña
ese refugio
y en ese lugar sabes que vas a encontrar
un techo
comida
y cerveza fresca para tomar
qué sentimiento tendría qué sensación
que nacimiento de esperanza les traería
esa cabaña ahí
marcial sánchez del moro potente y esta
es la historia del nacimiento de una
marca
vamos a hablar de ella un poco más
adelante porque eso que está ahí tiene
toda una explicación
la vida de realmente está hecha de
emociones vamos todos los días nos
enfrentábamos una vez tras otra a una
serie de retos problemas y dificultades
y realmente todos esos fracasos de esas
tristezas ese dolor ese sufrimiento esas
pequeñas alegrías que no llegan al
momento de epifanía se van acumulando
como una inmensa bola de nieve
hasta que llegó un momento en la vida en
que la acumulación de frustraciones de
dolor de fracasos de alegrías y toda
esta vorágine
explota y se quiebra y escucha en ese
crujir de una rama seca dentro de su
corazón y en su mente y en ese momento
escuchan ese sonido que hace que algo se
destruyó algo se quebró
cuando nosotros comenzamos foro potente
éramos una marca cool lo que seguimos
siendo cool
pero no éramos una marca importante en
los bares donde vendíamos éramos con los
bares querían tener muro potente pero
honestamente nuestro volumen de ventas
no les movía la aguja y eso implica que
quedaba entonces ahí en un rincón
ante todos esos retos ante esa
dificultad trabajábamos todos los días
durante seis años
viendo como lográbamos realmente
nosotros obtener los beneficios de haber
sido los que habíamos apostado más y era
duro y frustrante ver a un montón de
gente hacer plata con nuestra marca
mientras nosotros realmente que éramos
los que más habíamos apostado
no estábamos ganando nada todo ese
momento de frustración de miedo de
incertidumbre para llegar a ese
rompimiento que en algunas marcas puede
dilatar dos días otras marcas puede
dilatar diez años que un proceso natural
de la vida todo eso va pasando y cuando
se rompe cuando se quiebra por completo
cuando ya no tienes nada que perder y al
menos eso es lo que sentí mientras algún
momento de meditación un momento de
silencio hay un momento de reflexión
ese momento particular en el que todo el
miedo y la incertidumbre de la situación
anterior se convierte más bien en una
búsqueda de oportunidades
a ese momento nosotros le llamamos en
y en el caso de de la marca en cuestión
nosotros decidimos después de la ruptura
tenemos que tener nuestros propios bares
porque solo nuestros bares nuestra
cerveza va a tener el lugar que se
merece
y empezamos a cranear como se va a
llamar esos bares como se van a llamar
qué nombre le vamos a poner
y
imagínense o sea amor o potente
literatura se inspira en arte se inspira
en música tenemos una cerveza que se
llama 19 días inspirada en joaquín
sabina tenemos una cerveza que se llama
lado oscuro y mirada ya saben en quién
tenemos una cerveza que se llama one que
mira en toda la mitología miskita de
nicaragua tenemos una de mis favoritas
la lola inspirada en una prostituta
tenemos otra que se llama la maga
inspirada en una en la novela de julio
cortázar en rayuela y en el personaje de
la vela entonces
como vamos a crear una marca de bares de
moró potente que se llama el moro bar
o el moro pop o el rincón del moro
y eso nos costó mucho realmente nos
costó mucho trabajo hasta que un día
estás en esta etapa meditación en esta
etapa se en de meditación hasta que un
día conversando con mi mamá me contó una
historia de geo guau aquí está
resulta que mi bisabuelo que era el que
le decían el moro potente
así un viaje entre estelí jinotega y
pasaba por una core pequeña cordillera
que hay un pueblito ahí que se llama la
concordia lo hacían en carreta y
cruzando el viaje hacia en un descanso
en una finca que tenían que era su
refugio ahí se guarecían ahí descansaban
ahí comían y en ese momento yo dije aquí
está
si lo que estamos buscando es el refugio
para nuestros seguidores es el lugar
donde al final del día puede llegar y
tomarte una cerveza porque es el gusto
que te quiere dar y te quieres tomar una
buena cerveza y que también se le pide
que esté fría porque te lo mereces
esos pequeños lujos accesibles a los que
la clase media podemos darnos
y que para la clase media importan ese
plato de comida especial que querías
comer ese par de zapatos que te gustaban
esos pequeñitos que le line de miranda
nos regaña esos gustito que te puede dar
ese postre que te puedes comer entonces
resulta que la finca se llama paso león
y dijimos aquí está el refugio este es
el refugio de nuestra marca este es el
refugio para los que descubrí
y de esa meditación y de ese momento
viene otra etapa que es
tan importante
y aquí es donde viene lo más difícil
muchacho estás parado en el borde del
abismo
amarrado de una cuerda
haciendo wang yi y sabes que la cuerda
se puede romper
pero golpeas la mesa y escuchas ese
toque y esa es la toma de decisión
el momento en el que ya no hay vuelta
atrás en el momento en el que tu
confianza en vos mismo llega a su máximo
nivel y la incertidumbre disminuye a su
menor nivel pero nunca desaparece porque
no sabes necesariamente cómo lo vas a
hacer no sabes necesariamente si tenés
las herramientas no estás seguro
realmente de lo que viene pero algo en
vos te dice llegó el momento hay que
hacerlo y desde el salto efe
y da el brinco y entonces ahí todas las
piezas del rompecabezas terminan armando
si es cuando tu marca realmente
nace
este proceso al que nosotros enumeró
potente le llamamos cram sentó que es un
proceso natural
te da
una marca con storytelling sumamente
poderoso porque es storytelling nace
precisamente de tu vida de la realidad
de la vida no estás vendiendo humo estás
contando tu historia sus emociones sus
dificultades tus frustraciones tus
alegrías
por lo tanto por defecto vos sos el
mejor vendedor de esa marca que puede
haber porque lo que estás hablando desde
tu vida y ese proceso
esas tres sílabas ese momento de
acumulación de frustraciones que te
llevan luego a un momento de meditación
y de ese momento de meditación te lleva
a una toma de decisión a una acción
lo más interesante de todo eso es que
ese momento se vuelve a repetir una y
otra y otra vez porque en el mismo
instante que da el salto
el campo vuelve a comenzar
y eso es lo que viene
así que
a veces
queremos
darle vida a una marca
e intentando darle vida a una marca
nos terminamos dando vida a nosotros
mismos
una vida que se destruye se reconstruye
y se reinventa
cada vez y cada cuánto
en este interminable ciclo del gran
centro de la vida gracias
[Aplausos]